Somali American model her name is Halima
Adhan remember this is breaking barriers
in the fashion world
Adhan made history in 2016 when she wore
a bikini and a job during the Miss
Minnesota USA pageant the next year she
became the first hijab wearing model
designed with IMG Models ad and has
since appeared on the covers of british
vogue allure and vogue arabia she is now
cover star of Teen Vogue's new July
issue as part of its cover story Teen
Vogue Teen Vogue rather film Adhan on a
trip back to Kakuma that's a refugee
camp in Kenya where she was born so what
do you guys want to be when you grow up
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh my gosh I mean I really miss coming
here oh my gosh she says today the
United Nations Children's Fund known as
UNICEF is announcing that Halima Adhan
is its newest ambassador go you good
morning and she joins us at the table
you've got such an amazing life story
Halima I mean your story of so many
first in your life and you said you've
never run away from first and even being
born in a refugee camp you say to
yourself or you want people to know you
don't feel like a victim no and you
never have because because it has
everything to do with the way I viewed
the camp I mean I was a child but I had
no say in my circumstances and I always
had faith that I'm here for a reason you
know like it was not a mistake that we
were those were the cards that my family
was dealt with so I think that has a lot
to do with like my positive outlook on
even the camp because very well your
family walked 12 days to get from Somali
to Kenya you said you had a great
childhood yeah yeah tell us that because
we didn't have toys in the camp but we
had each other we had this sense of
community and my mom moved us around the
camp to make sure like we felt
comfortable with the other people that
were living there and she wanted from an
early age for me to be accepting of
differences and different cultures and I
think that has a lot to do with who I am
right you've said that being being named
the UNICEF ambassador is your proudest
accomplishment to date yeah why because
my mom can pick up a Vogue magazine and
she doesn't really understand but when I
told her about UNICEF she started crying
you know when I told her that news it
was like the first time in my modelling
career that she was really truly proud
of me because I think it's like a
difference in culture and she doesn't
understand like the impact of being
represented for the first time but she
does understand me working with UNICEF
mmm-hmm yeah you've also said that you
feel guilty sometimes and you want to
make sure that you've made the best of
the opportunity how do you feel guilty I
feel guilty because for my family to get
out that means millions of other
families never got that opportunity so
there are so many little girls out there
that will never see the opportunities
that I
had you know and it wasn't easy like I
took my family years to go through the
vetting process to get into the country
but I feel like okay I got here now what
am I going to do with my life how can I
make sure that I'm empowering the girls
that will never have that opportunity
that I did it's rare in America to see a
model wearing a hijab and when I read
about you you actually made it part of
your modeling contract right I mean
explain that what was the give-and-take
culturally so for me I think it's also
seeing how am I like my my mom is a very
strong woman and even though she's
illiterate she's still very powerful and
when I got that opportunity to sign with
IMG Models I made sure I wasn't
conforming and our first our first ever
like sit down was like four hours and it
was what I'm comfortable with what my
turn like I didn't on my own terms maybe
they receptive to that by the way oh
they loved it yeah they were super
supportive and every time I go on set I
know like the people who are doing this
shoot there are they already know my
requirements they know what I can wear
what like they've already had an
understanding and I always felt safe but
think of you as a little refugee girl
who's now a mod who is now a top model
because did you enter a beauty pageant
contest and you were discovered yeah
that's what happened - yeah
so this this is like this is why I say I
don't think life is an accident so in
2016 there was a small stabbing that had
that happened in my community actually
in st. cloud and then that had the media
attention and huffington post came down
to like interview me just because I went
to a CSU yeah and at a peace rally just
to bring the Somali community and like
everyone else together to be like were
United we're not gonna let this since
defiantly divide us I was - there was a
photograph that was taken of me playing
with this white baby because he kept
honking at my hijab and that went viral
in my state and then it's just like one
thing after another and then I did the
pageant for scholarship money for school
and then you were our ambassador
sorry I leaned ahead and thank you so
much for being with us this morning
really you're just getting started do
and you can find a link to Teen Vogue
story and film about halima on our
website CBS this morning calm